en este caso que ya como vemos si lo
acaba de comentar están en varios países
desde hace es posible que uno es lo que
se detecta y otros que todavía siguen
circulando y lo que nos ha mostrado las
buenas variantes anteriores es que
probablemente al circular o cortar los
vuelos lo que hace es mitigar 12 unos
cinco días o una semana dos semanas pero
definitivamente las variantes y tiene
las características biológicas de
poderse desplazar o diseminar finalmente
lo hace como ya lo vimos en con el caso
la variante delta de la que provenía de
la india ya veces eso es injusto también
decir que proviene o que cava aparece en
la india como el caso la variante de
esta o en suráfrica para este caso
porque lo que pasa es que puede ser el
país donde los piezas detectan y no
necesariamente que sea el único país que
lo tiene entonces realmente tenemos que
ser conscientes en que lo que podría
hacer es retardar algunas veces esa
llegada pero definitivamente va a llegar
y se va a diseminar como ocurre con
otras variantes y biológicamente tiene
una mayor afinidad para atarte a la
transmisión entre seres humanos